let's talk renting now this might be
controversial but i'm a finance guy i'm
a millionaire straight up i have a net
worth of over a million dollars and i
rent you might be like what the f is
wrong with this guy let me explain
renting all right so let's talk about
this so now they say that 48 of renters
worry they won't ever be able to buy a
home this is a survey according to cnbc
now here are the stats on
um on renting yeah 48 of renters here's
the stats you know two-thirds of people
own and one-third of people rent so the
question is do you have to buy in order
to build wealth now
keep in mind if two-thirds of people are
renting okay that's a majority of
americans question for you
why are three quarters of americans
living paycheck to paycheck
huh it would seem like a lot of those
people
own their houses so what am i saying
here so just because you buy a house
doesn't mean that you're automatically
going to be wealthy it definitely
doesn't mean you're not going to live
paycheck to paycheck in fact fun fact
for you the truth is the u.s middle
class this is quote unquote from the
article depend on their home equity as a
source of wealth way more than wealthy
families who tend to own more stocks
bonds or businesses so you're saying the
middle class depends on the value that
they'll get for their home 100 more than
the actual rich people do
that's exactly what i'm saying gotcha so
this might be controversial if there's
realtors out there that's the mentality
here's here's a little fun fact for you
do you know how many realtors i know who
rent
so many
so many i'm not
you know how many people i i know that
work in the stock market business
financial advisors ria's yada yada yada
that don't own stocks zero
so what does that mean what does that
mean what does that mean what does that
mean what am i trying to say
is that if you work in the stock market
like like you could you believe in
stocks yeah okay if you work in because
any because whether you have five grand
whether you have 10 grand or you have
100 grand of a million you can put that
in the market now i know a lot of
realtors who are like yeah now's not a
good time to buy it's a little too
expensive i want to stay flexible i'm
just saving money i'm renting i'm like
okay
so not every freaking realtor owns
property got it
okay in fact the realtor who's dude
found my lease for the last five
apartments that guy stays renting and
does very well for himself
so i'm like okay okay i got it you don't
have to buy in order to build wealth
dude there's a there's a savings
mechanism into renting what's that it's
like it's like me pouring you a glass of
a dark liquid i mean like here drink
this and you're like cool do you want
some i'm like no
that's like why aren't you drinking it
yeah okay coffee what is it yeah no just
drink it just drink it but dude did you
have some no no do you want some no
put drink up yeah and buy it buy it for
me coffee buy some of this so it sounds
like i'm hating on realtors i'm not it
sounds like i'm hating on buying a house
i'm not i'm just saying i'm hating on
the philosophy that renting is throwing
away money let's get into this story
thank you i'm gonna send this link to my
mother and my entire family of course
because the whole thing that i've been
like instilled with my dad my mom
everyone's like buy a home it's yours
it's land
the sopranos
we've talked about this all the time
what's worked for the boomers ain't
exactly gonna work for millennials i'm
just about to get to that we and we've
done this before new dogs can't be doing
old tricks
the world is moving so fast these days
you can't just take conventional wisdom
and just apply it and think it's gonna
work out for you i'm a puppy go to
college buy a house get married have
kids
stay in debt
no i'm good on all that let me figure
this out my own way yeah let me work
from home let me be an entrepreneur let
me not go to college let me rent let me
let me buy crypto like things are
changing so fast these days you can't
just do what people have always done for
decades and decades and decades and
expect to get ahead and we'll get into
that in a second
so
you know let's talk about renting for a
second because this is an episode on
renting so whether you're looking to buy
or rent now regardless prices are
freaking wild right now prices are to
the moon as they say yeah but if you're
renting you know
there's something called lease renewal
time so this is a story about basically
what you should be doing when your lease
comes due like mine is coming due in
january no and i got some things that i
got to figure out my friend
so basically you know
buying a home is like getting married
renting a home is like dating we're
going to figure it out we all know what
happens to 50 of marriages they end in
divorce a lot of times like my business
partner my other business
the wife got the house and he had to pay
her 10 grand a month
out of alimony
just saying
just saying it's not always peaches and
roses when uh when you get married you
have a house
so it's a huge commitment fifty percent
single day i would say that all right
well that being said a single guy would
say that look i'm i'm just stating the
facts no i hear you so i could get some
hated on i come good some people say you
know what this guy's thousands got a
point i'm putting things out there that
aren't typically talked about that's my
point this is why i've
been able to
save that money invest that money become
a millionaire by being a renter i'll
explain this to you so when i was 30
years old i just started to make some
money i had a roommate my boy we were
splitting the rent it was like a 3 000
unit downtown miami we're each paying
1500 bucks to buy that unit i would have
probably had to pay
four thousand dollars a month myself so
now i'm paying 1500 bucks with a
roommate so understand that if i was
gonna buy that unit which i was not even
considering that's about two three
thousand dollars i'm saving every single
month so what am i doing with that money
i'm saving it i'm investing it i'm
maxing out my 401k i'm basically doing
what i talk about here i'm using rent to
my advantage then i moved in with my
girl we were two people in one unit cool
i was paying the rent she was paying the
utilities so i'm paying three thousand
she's paying 200 cool it's a good deal
whatever i move and then we broke up
with my girl i moved into that bachelor
pad that i talked about right 35 so i'm
moving i'm moving i'm grooving then next
thing you know pat says dude why don't
you move to dallas
and come team up with me at
valuetainment cool done my lease is up
i'm moving to dallas not paying a
thousand bucks for a little one bedroom
in dallas because all i'm doing is
working so i'm i'm flex i got
flexibility galore pat says hey good
news we're leaving dallas we're moving
back to boca south florida cool great
get a unit here now hey good news we're
actually moving to fort lauderdale boom
done with the lease state flexibility is
key bro unless you know where you're
going to be for the next 5 10 20 [ __ ]
years
renting is perfectly fine
perfectly fine
now
everyone says renting is throwing away
money throwing away money throwing my
money not if you're saving that money to
invest
okay if you're not saving any money
you're not investing just buy a house
and be done with it
no brainer at least your home will go up
three to five percent a year who knows
and when you sell it you can make some
money sure but if you're just renting
you got to have a game plan with your
money you got to look at the big picture
so
you know how to say the one constant in
life is change things are changing stay
flexible keep your head on a swivel if
you've got cash and you're and you're
renting and you can stay flexibly go
wherever you want
low overhead
high flexibility key to life i've said
it before i'll say it again low overhead
keeping your cost as low as possible and
keeping your flexibility as high as
possible is the key to life disease the
world is moving so fast unless you've
got kids and school districts and like a
mortgage in a house and you know you
ain't moving if you're young do not feel
the pressure to have to buy a house i'm
telling you it's worked out for me i'm
moving to a different place every couple
years yeah i gotta pay some moving costs
but boom i'm saving thousands and
thousands of thousand dollars a year and
i'm putting that right into the stock
market you know the beautiful thing
about investing in the stock market you
take that [ __ ] anywhere whether i'm
living in florida new york or freaking
iceland working four days a week i could
take my money with me you can't do that
with a mortgage you're set in stone
literally
so there it is
um but the little little tidbit with the
rent make sure your rent is
at most as much as you can 30 of your
take-home pay we did this a couple
episodes ago yeah if you're making 50 gs
a year 30 of that 15 grand
um
which i think of 1250 a month so anyway
that's that's your number yeah so
i know i'm going ham on this you might
have realtors out there like this guy i
know what he's [ __ ] talking about i
probably have more money than you do
damn damn just like that you just said
that just i said it
because i understand the game plan i
understand that if i'm renting i can't
be spending all my freaking money and i
have to invest yeah if you're if you're
just gonna rent and piss away all your
money just buy a place dude and don't
even overthink it
so here's something that i actually
found out we're gonna say something i
rented a place while you were going uh
[Laughter]
if you're renting yeah and you're not
saving that money and investing and
putting money into your 401k roth ira
investing what have you you're losing
straight up you're losing the money game
you're renting and you're not doing that
stuff you're losing you're losing right
if you're renting
and you're saving that money and you're
investing and you're basically
understanding that it's a savings
mechanism to increase your
investments and your savings and you're
understanding the the game plan of what
you're doing and you have flexibility to
move around and move and groove you're
winning cha-ching thank you if you
enjoyed that short clip from the size
sawzcast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke